the sound
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to guess
what I just saw trailer for that's right
the next and pray to God last of the
Paranormal Activity lock you under
Taemin I don't have to say now if you're
like me you probably rolled your eyes
like the majority of the audience that
saw this trailer which is funny because
before Paranormal Activity was the movie
you had to fight to see you had to call
up your movie theater to have it play
there in an ingenious marketing campaign
now we've seen that so damn much that
we're sick of it and for many we're also
sick of found footage films everyone I
talked to says they're done with it
there's just nothing left it's not a
genre it's a gimmick and it needs to go
out of style most people can't take the
motion sickness camera in two dimensions
but now we're gonna add three to it dude
this needs to stop but then again there
must have been something that drew us to
this for such a long period of time were
these really just cheap ways to make
horror films with just a person holding
a crappy camera to answer this we got to
go back to one the hole found footage
things started right leastwise started
to get popular that's what the Blair
Witch Project now chances are this kind
of idea had been done before but this is
the first time it became a worldwide
phenomenon the hype for this movie was
insane but even from day one people were
split about it some say it was one of
the scariest movies ever made others say
there were no scares at all some praised
it as a new form of filmmaking others
saw it as a lazy shaky cam mess
whatever your thought process the film
was a big hit inspiring dozens of other
films trying something similar and
ironically the sequel be nothing like
the first one you all know the set up
the whole film is being told from the
point of view of a person holding the
camera and while it's debatable whether
or not Blair Witch holds up depending on
the ask you can't ignore what it
inspired we went from two cameras to
multiple cameras quick edits to shots
that take up the entire night crappy
quality to really high end
so this means that the art form must
have evolved right well again it depends
on who you ask
while the imagery looked better many say
the quality of the scares was getting
predictable and the limitations too
frustrating
there's always shaky can there's always
people reacting to the camera like
they've never fucking seen one before
there's always a ton of comedy in the
first half and of course the characters
always have to unrealistically film
everything
well maybe not someone realistically
nowadays but still this is pushing it
it's understandable why people would
start to get sick of this still large
part of any genre is the limitations and
the discipline you assigned to it in
film noir you know you're going to get
heavy shadows in the dark mysterious
story in romances you know you're always
going to get to people who share their
emotions and their feelings to grow
closer so why can't these limitations
work for the genre found-footage not
true this has been used in comedies and
dramas so it's probably more appropriate
to call that sub-genre but it's still a
distinct style with the distinct look
that many filmmakers have added their
own touch too on top of that while
repetitive in many areas it has opened
up a new variety of scares the
Paranormal Activity movies despite the
stories and characters becoming less
developed do still offer new ways of
scaring people yeah we get those faked
out jump scares that are always awful
but then there's ideas like the camera
going back and forth slowly revealing
the scare or literally dangling a knife
off-screen never knowing when it's gonna
fall or even just moving spots fucking
moving spots can suddenly become
terrifying it's this kind of simplicity
that can get the biggest frights with
the subtlest of actions one of my
favorite edits is in Paranormal Activity
2 when the daughter thinks something is
taken over her mother we get a scene of
the mother about to confront her in a
room and then we just cut to the
daughter crying on the phone asking for
help we have no idea what happened in
between but our imagination is much more
disturbing than anything it could have
shown and seeing how a lot of found
footage is very much less is more it
allows clever touches like that to shine
the best when it has to work through the
limitations by being clever it's like
shooting an entire movie in a coffin
and our whole film on a chairlift when
you take away the usual distractions it
allows you to focus more on the meat of
the story and it can only be done well
by truly smart filmmakers but with that
said a lot of times the style can be the
distraction the master of zombie films
George a Romero's his stab at the found
footage style and failed miserably
nothing ever looked like actual found
footage it was too well shot too nice
sounding and too much acted like a
Hollywood film something like this makes
you realize not only is there a right
way to do found footage but there's a
logical reason for why it can work what
the horror movies as well as most movies
try to do they try to make you feel like
you're in the film so you can identify
more with the situation but where most
movies need to film a main character
we found footage the main character is
the one that's filming so it's much
easier to make you feel like you're the
one in the situation when it works it
can get some of the biggest scares you
can imagine but the downside is people
are much more critical and rightfully so
not believing the environment or
characters in a found footage movie is
10 times worse than if you don't believe
it in any other genre because the whole
point is to make you feel like you're
really there and if the story characters
are acting are so far-fetched that it
knocks you out of that illusion the film
falls apart the majority of the
Paranormal Activity movies have good
scares but because they had to make them
so fast one every year the stories got
too silly for most people and the
characters choices became unrelatable
this is why the next film looks so bad
because rather than convincing us that
they fix the problems they're throwing
more gimmicks and more distracting
visuals that are just looking fake now
they're trying to go bigger in a series
that thrived on minimalism oh that's it
sometimes new twists can come from the
most unlikely of places unfriended
spends the whole movie on a girl's
computer screen this limitation allowed
us not only to see the cost of living
too much on social media but also how
unlikable most dumb teens and horror
movies are at first you think you're
supposed to like these people like in
most Garre movies but by the end you
realize not only are you supposed to
find them all revolting but that teens
in most scary films are you
we shall leave revolting it's a good way
to use satire while also moving your
story forward and upping the atmosphere
again using very little to achieve an
awful lot and speaking of mixing comedy
and horror who would have thought M
night Shyamalan would be able to mix the
two so well the visit was a hit with
both critics and audiences and while it
still has is a lot boring writing all
over it it did manage to create a
scenario where you're both screaming and
laughing both at the same time no you
know there's a ton of holes in the movie
like how is that tiny camera getting
that good quality or how are there
non-existent mics picking up everything
the weird atmosphere it creates Maja's
to be both charming and disturbing
simultaneously and the found footage
style helps that there's a scene where
the grandma chases the kids under the
house and it's scary because you see
literally what they see and therefore
fear what they fear but when you're
further away from it like they are you
see she was just playing a game oh yeah
I guess we're kind of jumping to
conclusions
right the point of view of the camera
blurs that line throughout the majority
of the film leaving the mystery tougher
to figure out the last exorcism was
another great blend of horror and comedy
as a film group follows an exorcist who
claims he's a sham and we laugh at his
clever ways of convincing mentally ill
people that he's getting demons out of
them but when he comes across one that
seems too real even for him it's led to
the viewer to decide whether the girl is
actually possessed or not there's no
flashbacks close-ups or inner monologues
to give you any clues it's only what the
camera picks up it's another layer of
limitation that actually helps the
mystery of the storytelling that is
until the bullshit ending but let's not
go there
no really I'm telling to Phil not to go
there you were so good until that many
of these movies I'm talking about are
years old but some of them are rather
reasoned meaning that there's still
possibilities that can be done with this
type of filmmaking can it get annoying
yes do the limitations stunt the growth
at times certainly but clever filmmaking
is clever filmmaking and if someone has
a twist on a popular idea there's no
reason to stop them
and if you can never get into them and
the motion sickness is just too much for
you it's completely understandable
everyone's gonna have a style or genre
that's just not gonna grab them
but I think for most of us it's like
watching a trailer from Wes Anderson or
quitting Tarantino you always kind of
say you're done with that style that's
the same thing over and over but then
when you see them do something really
really good with it
you remember that style can help a story
and you're reminded of why you start to
watch it to begin with film footage is
more than just a person holding a camera
it's a surprisingly complicated method
of filmmaking that allows fewer mistakes
and many would expect more elements have
to gel together to please the audience
for a found footage film than say the
audience for a Michael Bay film because
there's less distractions you have to be
sure what you have is convincing while
still telling an engaging narrative
former is already difficult on its own
so throwing in these limitations makes
it even tougher but when it works it can
really work and lead down new avenues
that didn't exist before it's hard to
say whether or not the new Paranormal
Activity will be any good but it's not
worth condemning a style of film that
can and has given some memorable scares
for it is there gonna be crap with it
sure just like any genre has a lot of
crap but for those who know how to not
only work within this realm but also we
volve it to a new level the
possibilities are just too intriguing to
turn down I'm gonna stab your critic I
shake the camera so you don't have to
okay seriously stop that
you
hey the Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing
DuPage pads this is an organization that
specializes in helping people who are
homeless they help find shelters they
help give them resources they are done
mostly through volunteers a lot of the
volunteers are younger people and
teenagers they like to start them young
showing that it's good to help people
who do not have a home and it isn't just
adults there's many families and young
children all these people need a home
and they specialize in a place where the
weather can just be brutal this is in
DuPage County and the weather can either
get extremely hot or it can get
extremely cold as May you know we have
really bad storms here and it can just
get so tough so this is an organization
that tries it's best to help give people
a home just a shelter just something
away from the harsh conditions that
there can be out there and they try
everything they can to try and get these
people back on their feet and try to
find good resources and good people that
can help them out and they do everything
that they can and they have all sorts of
fundraisers and events they have
something where they do a run a run for
home as they call it they also have an
auction called taste for hope we're all
sorts of wonderful restaurants come in
and donate their time and food and I've
been to a lot of these restaurants there
they're good stuff so it isn't just the
bare minimum
they try everything they can to try and
get these people a warm place where they
can feel safe and they can feel secure
and you can definitely make a big
difference in that any little amount
helps please definitely check out their
website and contribute to people who so
deserve a warm place to feel safe
you